even through the heat firefighter  continued their progress on the sandy  valley fire flames have scorched about  thirteen hundred acres on mount podese  between las vegas and prompt  the last update from the blm shows  containment at about 90 percent  full containment is expected in the next  few days  crews are also working on another  wildfire just down the road from there  according to the blm this one was human  cause  the cottonwood valley fire started about  11 o'clock this morning off state route  160.  according to the nevada wildfire  information map at last check  it has grown to about 200 acres there is  zero containment to report